-Well, it was
another super-chill weekend
with the President
of the United States
retweeting a deranged
conspiracy theory
accusing a previous president
of murder.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Donald Trump has changed many
things in his life,
but there are a few constants.
He's always been a racist,
he's always been a con artist,
and he's always been
a conspiracy theorist.
Trump has paranoid fantasies
about everything
from climate change
to government surveillance
to the food he eats.
According to the book
"Fire and Fury,"
he had a long-time fear
of being poisoned,
one reason why he liked to eat
at McDonald's.
Nobody knew he was coming,
and the food was safely premade.
Okay, first of all,
at this point,
I think they know you're coming.
You are the norm of McDonald's.
If you want to catch
a restaurant off guard,
walk into a Just Salad.
Also really hammers home how
anti-science our president is
that he eats fast food
to avoid being poisoned.
[ As Trump ]
"My body is a temple.
Two Filet-o-Fish, please."
[ Normal voice ]
During a 2016 town hall on CNN,
Trump basically admitted it
to Anderson Cooper.
-I'm a person
that I like cleanliness,
I like clean, and the one thing
about the big franchises --
You have to have a certain --
You know,
because of the importance --
One bad hamburger,
you could destroy a McDonald's.
you take Wendy's
and all these other places,
and they're out of business.
You can't do it.
So, I'm a very clean person.
I like cleanliness.
And I think you're better off
going there
than maybe some place
that you have no idea
where the food's coming from.
-First of all, I would not call
you a very clean person.
The only clean thing about you
is your desk,
and that's because
you don't do anything.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look at that.
That looks like a Hollywood tour
where they let you take a photo
on the set of "The West Wing."
[ Laughter ]
There's not a single piece
of paper on that desk.
When the next president
moves in, all they're gonna find
are the water rings left
by his Diet Cokes.
Also, you only think
McDonald's are clean
because you send other people
to pick up the food.
You based your opinion of
McDonald's on the commercials.
[ As Trump ] "Here's the money.
And remember -- Only take food
directly from the clown.
He's the only one I trust."
[ Normal voice ]
Of course, Trump launched
his political career
by fabricating
a racist conspiracy theory about
President Obama's birthplace,
and it wasn't just that Trump
accused Obama
of being born in Kenya.
He also invented
an insane fantasy
where Obama had faked documents,
and at one point,
he even claimed his own
investigators were
discovering evidence that proved
Obama was hiding the truth.
-Three weeks ago,
when I started,
I thought he was probably born
in this country,
and now I really have a much
bigger doubt than I did before.
-He doesn't have
a birth certificate,
or he hasn't shown it.
He has what's called
a certificate of live birth.
That is something
that's easy to get.
When you want
a birth certificate,
it's very hard to get.
-But it's considered the
equivalent in the state --
-Excuse me.
It's not the equivalent.
-In the state of Hawaii,
they said they have seen
his document.
-I saw his.
I read it very carefully.
Doesn't have a serial number.
Doesn't have a signature.
There's not even a signature.
-The biggest lie in that
interview was Trump saying
Obama didn't have
a birth certificate.
The second biggest lie
was Trump saying
he read something carefully.
[ Laughter ]
I'd be shocked if he could make
it through something
as long as a birth certificate.
To help him fall asleep
at night,
he probably reads
a business card.
[ As Trump ]
"Oh, they also have fax!"
[ Normal voice ] Anyway,
continue with your bull[bleep].
-I have people that have
actually been studying it,
and they cannot believe
what they're finding.
-You have people now down there
searching in Hawaii?
-Absolutely. And they cannot
believe what they're finding.
-He said that eight years ago,
and he's never once explained
what they were finding,
and the reason is
because there were
no investigators
searching for documents
in Hawaii.
If he did send
anyone down there,
it was probably
his two weird sons.
"You can't believe
what we're finding, Dad!
Their rocks have juice in them!"
[ Laughter ]
"Did you tell him
about the juice rocks?!"
"I'm telling him right now!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump even went so far
as to claim
that the contemporaneous
newspaper accounts
of Obama's birth
in local Hawaiian newspapers
had to have been faked.
-There were two announcements
the week he was born
in both Honolulu newspapers
saying that he was born, okay?
That is impossible
to make happen
if he had not been born
in the hospital.
So, I just dismissed it, but
you made a big deal out of it.
-Bill, I grew up
with Wall Street geniuses.
What they do in terms of fraud
and how they change documents --
And I'll tell you something.
If you notice, those dates were
three days later,
and here's what I ask people.
Who puts announcements?
Here are two poor people, a man
and a woman with no money.
They have a baby. There's
announcements in the newspaper?
-The grandparents did it.
-The grandparents.
Nelson Rockefeller doesn't put
announcements --
-Sure, there are birth
announcements all the time.
-I've never seen one.
-Really?!
-No, I've never seen one.
-No, they're common.
-I've never seen one.
-Maybe you've never seen one
because your parents
never did one for you.
If anything, they probably took
out an add that said,
"Donald Trump was born.
We're sorry."
Then, of course, there's
the racist conspiracy theory
that Trump has repeated since
he was elected
that millions
of undocumented immigrants
are voting illegally
in states like California.
In fact, he just repeated
it last month in a speech
to a group
of young conservatives,
and it barely registered
as a blip on the news
because we're so numb to it now.
-And then those illegals get out
and vote
because they vote anyway.
Don't kid yourself.
Those numbers in California
and numerous other states,
they're rigged.
You got people voting
that shouldn't be voting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They vote many times,
not just twice,
not just three times,
they vote -- it's like a circle.
They come back,
they put a new hat on.
they put a new shirt on.
And in many cases,
they don't even do that.
You know what's going on.
-I love the moment he's like,
[as Trump] "Oh, [bleep]
what's the word for this?
Uh, I know there's a --
I'm gonna fall back on circle!"
[ Normal voice ]
Trump has always been
an unhinged conspiracy theorist,
and we saw that on display
yet again this weekend
when he retweeted
an insane conspiracy theory
tying the Clintons to the death
of convicted pedophile
and accused sex trafficker
Jeffrey Epstein.
-We begin this morning
with a retweet
from the President
of the United States.
Not a message about healing
or uniting the country
one week after
two horrifying massacres,
not about the victims
of those tragedies.
Instead, President Trump, using
his massive Twitter platform,
63 million followers, to spread
a deranged conspiracy theory
tying the death of pedophile
Jeffrey Epstein in prison
to the President's former
political rivals, the Clintons.
I'm not gonna show you
the tweet.
-Think about that.
The President's tweets are
so insane,
the news can't even
show them now.
It's getting to the point where
when he talks to reporters,
they're gonna have to blur out
his entire face.
They're gonna have to treat him
like accidental nudity.
We elected President Nip Slip.
[ Laughter ]
Trump's penchant for peddling
insane conspiracy theories
isn't just
a weird personality quirk.
It has real consequences
for real people.
For example, he's repeatedly
given voice to the racist
and anti-Semitic
conspiracy theory
that Democrats and the Jewish
philanthropist George Soros
are somehow funding a plot
to have refugees invade
the United States by organizing
caravans of migrants.
-The Democrats want caravans.
They like the caravans.
A lot of people say, "I wonder
who started that caravan."
You know how
the caravan started?
Does everybody know
what this means?
I think the Democrats had
something to do with it.
-Do you think somebody's
funding the caravan?
Do you think anyone's
paying for the caravan?
-I wouldn't be surprised.
Yeah, I wouldn't be surprised.
-George Soros?
-I don't know who,
but I wouldn't be surprised.
A lot of people say yes.
-"I don't know who,
but a lot of people say yes."
He always tries to do this move
where he pretends
he doesn't know anything, but
a lot of people are saying it.
I'm starting to think
these people
are just other
Trump personalities.
Golf Trump says
it's the Democrats,
Sweaty Trump says it's Soros,
and Empty Desk Trump says,
"Cheese!"
Of course, Trump's not alone in
peddling this racist paranoia.
The right-wing media outlets
he loves and echos
constantly repeat
deranged theories
about invading refugees,
the same language used
by white supremacists.
In fact, multiple Fox hosts have
defended the President's use
of the word "invasion"
to describe desperate refugees
seeking asylum, including
Fox host Jeanine Pirro,
who used a very bizarre analogy
on her show Saturday night.
-Stop blaming the President
for this stuff.
Even the guy said
before President Trump,
"I didn't like the people
coming in,"
so let's stop blaming Trump.
-He used that rhetoric.
That's what makes it dangerous.
-Oh, come on.
-Hey, we all use
the same language!
We speak English!
So what?!
-I don't call illegal immigrants
"invaders."
-Yeah, well, a lot of people do.
You know, I watch cartoons,
they have invaders, too,
you know, from Mars.
Stop with this craziness!
-You can't say,
"Stop with the craziness"
right after you say,
"I watch cartoons,
and they have invaders
from Mars."
[ Laughter ]
That is as jarring as hearing
a dog scream, "No pets allowed."
-By the way,
the same weekend Trump retweeted
his deranged Epstein theory,
he was in the Hamptons
for a series of fundraisers
where tickets ran as high
as $250,000, which sums up
so much of our politics
right now --
a paranoid president spreading
unhinged racist conspiracies
while raking in millions from
a crowd of mega-rich supporters
who don't care as long as
they can line their own pockets.
Meanwhile, most sane people
are saying...
-Stop with this craziness!
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]